justice O'Connor and I were in India on
911 we had flown there we were meeting
with their judicial with the judges of
their Supreme Court we arrived on that
very day on that very day of course
people that were horrified and there was
a tremendous outpouring of support and
people couldn't have been nicer and but
it was a time for a thought and really
it seemed to me the the the and I
mention it because what was in our minds
after a week there we spent a week there
that the world is really divided into
the what I think of is the forces of
reason and the forces of non reason and
the forces of reason will law as part of
that law as part of it judges are part
of it lawyers are part of it and so is
everybody else on you know other
professions the forces of non reason
that's the risk that's the danger so I
rather see that as something that's
unifying people across the world because
people across the world do believe in
democratic systems they do believe in
protecting basic human rights they do
believe in trying to create economies
that will be make their people
prosperous and they believe to a
considerable degree in international
settlement of disputes things like that
too but there are forces that they have
to fight against which are obvious so
that's in my mind maybe that's how I was
brought up to you know it was after
world war two efforts at cooperation as
you look out today but also I'd say my
experience tells me that in a way it's
like this sort of somebody weaving a
loom I mean I'm not a political figure
I'm not in politics and I don't and and
people who do are are in politics and in
very high levels in government may see
these international institutions and
global politics going on at a very high
level but I say to the
and judges were technical people were
professionals and at our level whatever
happens at the other there is a kind of
knitting going on it's like workers at
ilume it's happening in Europe it's
happening in Africa it's happening in
Asia people are learning from each other
particularly in law how does it happen
it happens in conferences people talk to
each other judges talk to each other
lawyers talk to each other it happens as
different groups try to create laws for
example in Europe they're trying to
create commercial laws and bankruptcy
laws and tax laws and laws that will
govern several what we're in de pere are
independent nations but they're trying
to get together and this is happening so
the World Trade Organization it's
happening across the world it's
popularly called globalization but what
it involves are people in business
people in law learning what each other
are doing and they adjust their laws
accordingly it doesn't always have to be
formal we used to have a group called
the uniform law commissioners and they
go from state to state and they'd say
California does this and they go to Iowa
and they say Iowa you know California
does this maybe you should try it and
that kind of thing goes on every minute
as we speak and then there are there
there are different organizations
developing like the World Trade
Organization or or their their dozens of
them they're they're free trade areas
are there there there are health
organizations there are communications
organizations there's the Internet
they're all these things we know about
they are all forces working to bring us
together so what I see as happening and
it's not a political matter what I see
is happening is people who are lawyers
and judges in America today have to be
aware and they have to have a system for
being aware of what's going on elsewhere
because the case is in front of them
will more and more depend on what's
happening else
I heard Shimon for ssf a minister I
thought disease people are so
pessimistic about the Middle East and he
said something more optimistic he said
it's like it's like going forward with
with throwback sits there are obstacles
and you hope you'll surmount them and
you might there were right now you're
involved in the Internet well my
goodness that could be a terrible thing
it could be a force that isolates people
that they don't have human contact
anymore everything or it could be a
force that brings them together and in
fact when you see people in probably in
the Middle East he said once they start
to see what's possible elsewhere in the
world and what they can achieve through
cooperation in a modern world modern has
a lot of bad about it but it has a lot
of good and it whether it's good or bad
we're in it and once they see what what
what is possible to accomplish through
education through savings through trying
to improve their economic life through
getting together once they see that
they'll begin more to understand it and
that will be a tremendous civilizing
force and by civilizing force I mean the
force that that really keeps out these
incredible fanatics and so what we've
seen in the last ten years is there is
no magic solution there's a to me there
are no magic solutions to keeping them
out and I would be repeating myself I'd
go back and say that that's why what
you're doing is good you're getting
people to think and getting people to
learn what other people think
hey